[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and you'll get your spider-man no way
home trailer when you fix this damn door
there's still no sign of the first look
at the film but we do have some brand
new plot details
leaks and an animatic scene from the
ill-fated spider-man 4
i think will just be fun to show you
guys in this video we'll also be going
over the potential trailer release date
and what we think might be the reason
it's delayed full spoilers ahead so if
you don't want anything ruined then i
recommend you get out of here before i
throw some dirt in your eye
oh gonna cry now well shut the hell up
and like the video
and also subscribe or else anyway thanks
for sticking around past that bit
you know i love you really you know you
know i'm just joking now let's get into
the spider-man new details
now we did talk in our last video about
how william defoe's green goblin was
actually the big bad of the movie
from what i've heard on the film oz
cobra experimenting on inter-dimensional
technology
in order to access the multiverse
similar to kingpin in
into the spider-verse this works and it
actually gives him a way to go across
into other dimensions
now in peter's life he's just been
exposed worse than some youtube drama
and thus he's laying low at dr strange's
sanctum sanctorum as a wanted fugitive
images of this were posted online as the
first looks on the film
and we can definitely tell by the floor
pattern that this is the place ned mj
and peter go to
now they apparently find the location in
pretty bad shape and as we know strange
was dusted during the snap
so this is why the building is in
disrepair we'll talk about why he hasn't
had time to clean the place up in just a
bit
but it has a big tie into the plot from
what's been shown
we know that the group go down to the
basement and here they bust out the
laptop that ned had all the way back in
homecoming because
tony stark is a greedy piece of [ __ ]
that refuses to give anyone money
you're some of a [ __ ] i'm glad you're
dead i've been told that in the scene
the three read reports and see social
media reactions to the news that peter
parker is spider-man
see i told you there'd be spoilers they
then go back to the lobby of the
sanctorum
and this is where strange comes across
them if you look closely you can see
somewhat of an orange glow on their
faces and this is because strange is at
the top of the stairs illuminating this
room
turns out that peter parker picked the
perfect place to pass as strange is able
to wipe the memory that he's spider-man
from everyone's mind
and something similar was carried out in
the story one more day
which this movie is meant to be based
upon the spell somewhat goes off without
a hitch
and the knowledge is removed from
everyone's mind with only ned
mj aunt may and the avengers knowing who
he really is
at the sanctorum parker stumbles across
a multiversal prison
which is housing several villains from
across different properties
i've been told that the prison is a
stony dungeon with chains hanging from
the cells
and at the center is a magical cube
keeping them all in place
the lineup of prisoners includes doc ock
the lizard
electro and sandman strange says that
something has broken the multiverse and
that people from across
several dimensions have been brought
into the main timeline
now i kind of want to talk about my
trailer speculation date here as i think
this is probably the best place to do it
i speak to daniel rpk behind the scenes
quite a lot
and not only is he getting there what a
lovely chap heavy spoilers award
he's pretty much always been absolutely
bang on when it comes to trailer dates
and releases
he predicted the eternals trailer
release date correctly a quiet place too
the teaser for no way home shang chi
loki
black widow venom let there be carnage
and a lot more
for as long as i've known the guy he's
always been right and he's also helped
me to prepare for stuff
as when people were saying that the
trailer it's definitely going to be
dropping at a certain date
he's been there like it's it's not
happening mate don't build your hopes up
now i think over the last month alone
we've had about four different dates
when the no way home trailer was quote
unquote definitely coming out
and each and every time daniel has said
to me that it's not
now what he has said online is that it's
probably coming the last week of june
or first week of july and i think this
makes a lot of sense
however i also think that marvel might
hold off until loki is over
black widow is of course right around
the corner so that will be taking up a
lot of the marketing power at marvel
and loki as a show seems to be about the
collapse of the multiverse
thus i think the plot of that might
actually play into spiderman no way home
and kevin feige has said that loki won
division
no way home and doctor strange too oh
say it with me all connected
so i kind of feel like they may hold off
on that but the counter argument seems
to be that sony didn't wait for endgame
to release before dropping the trailer
for far from home
whilst that is true the marketing of
that was very smart and if you remember
they clearly pitched it as a field trip
which is something that peter was coming
back from in infinity war
so they passed it off as being somewhat
of a prequel even though most of us
guessed it was set after endgame and by
most of us i mean not me
because i'm an idiot thus i think that
it will come in july at some point
most likely a monday judging by the past
releases of the marvel trailers
and with these always dropping at 2pm
british summertime
i think sony will stick to that strategy
as it seems to work
now why this might not be true is
because sony marvel studios market their
things very differently
and from what i was told at the time
there were some issues behind the scenes
with the far from home trailer coming up
before endgame
but again different people marketing
stuff with different strategies
now i do think it would be short side of
them to drop it around the release of
black widow and finale of loki
but we will see because they just seem
like they couldn't give a [ __ ] out yes
spoiling everything
out here saying that venom's gonna be in
every movie without even talking with
feige
what the hell is wrong with you now back
to the leaks and the multiverse is
playing a major part as it means that
some of the characters can be tweaked
and changed
willem dafoe's green goblin for example
will be a very different one to the one
that was in the raimi verse
and he will have a brand new suit that's
far more similar to the one that was
originally supposed to be in the first
film
as we said in our last video electro's
costume is very different
to what he had on in the amazing
spider-man 2 and the villain is wearing
a hi-vis
electrical engineers jacket that's green
and yellow now it has been reported by
superhero theorist at murphy's
multiverse
that we will also see the conclusion of
the fight between the rhino and
spider-man
that ended andrew garfield's second film
rhino will also be one of the sinister
six films
and he actually gets some cool stuff to
do now peter is pretty worried that
strange is keeping people prisoner
against their will
but strange assures him that he's fixing
the multiverse and that he'll return
them home
peter says there's no way home and i
just made that bit up it's not the movie
anyway
norman osborne goes to them in their
prison and after realizing that
strange's magic is too strong for him to
break
he comes up with another plan osborne
asks each one of the prisoners what the
last thing they remember is
and they all collectively recall the
spider-man of their earth either beating
them
or being involved with their deaths
osborne then goes to peter with this
info
and says that they're gonna die if
they're returned home he also says that
the peter of their earth's killed them
and thus holland's parker feels guilty
as he's pretty much sentencing them to
death
peter apparently steals the magical cube
and strange chases him across the city
in the mirror dimension
whilst buildings collapse around them
during this time osborne makes his team
and they set out to steal several stock
reactors in order to help build a
multi-dimensional portal above
the statue of liberty this now has a
captain america shield on it
and above the statue they create a
doorway this is why strange pulls across
toby maguire and andrew garfield's
spider-man and from what i've heard
they're not in the film all that much
but when they're on screen
it feels like pizza time the movie keeps
topping itself
with a peter pepper army that fight the
villains off
the parker trio managed to cheese the
day and the movie ends with them saying
slice to meet you peter peter says these
pizza puns are a bit cheesy
and they reply with yeah we do seem like
a bit of a weird dough
but we're here today and gone tomorrow
now that that conversation here might
not happen exactly like that
but it's along the lines of them helping
out saying hello and then going
anyway that's all new plot deals i have
for you
and there's also been a brand new
animatic posted by david e duncan on
vimeo
i'm not sure of the copyright on things
like this so i'm just going to talk over
the top of it
so that it's at least fair use but i've
linked duncan's vimeo below if you want
to watch the full thing without an
annoying british dude
mumbling over the top of it now duncan
worked on spider-man 4
and over on his vimeo page he said the
following when discussing this clip
this is one of half a dozen animatics i
produced for the ill-fated fourth reimy
spider-man movie
studio politics creative differences
and bad internet reactions to john
malkovich's the vulture
caused the plug to be pulled december of
2009
however one month later sony moved
forward with the andrew garfield reboot
in case you don't know spider-man 4 was
originally meant to have the vulture
face off against toby maguire's peter
parker
spider-man 3 sort of derailed the
franchise a bit and it's clear that the
studio are attempting to go back to a
simplest story structure with one main
villain instead of several
the clip was actually supposed to be the
final battle and they do the old thing
of the villain finding out who
spider-man is
but unlike most of the other movies in
the franchise this just makes vulture
more angry
the animatic ends with peter beating
vulture and he crash lands
i'm not 100 sure if the final exchange
would have been through dialogue or not
as vulture clearly survives but this is
listed as the final battle
so mayor who knows anyway great clip of
what might have been
and i am hyped to see toby back in the
mcu as he's one of the best
of the three maybe i don't know depends
if you if you count the spider verse or
not but
he's one of one of the spider-man actors
that
people know now that's some more leaks
for your [ __ ] ass and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on them
as a thank you for commenting on the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3 epc box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the leaks
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want some meals to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the loki fan theory that peggy carter
could be seen in the first episode we've
gone over the entire thing
and also discussed some little easter
eggs that you might have missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care
and get that bleed damn door fix because
i want that trailer
goodbye